pour leur Taïwan et comme un îlot
démocratique au large des côtes de la
République populaire de Chine est la
même vue émergé une nouvelle génération
d'activistes démocrates comme vient de
nous le montrer à l'instant ce
documentaire réalisé par Alain leftovich
mais pour Pékin plus que jamais rien de
change elle demeure une province rebelle
qui devra un jour ou l'autre revenir
dans son Gironde de quoi s'interroger
bien entendu sur l'avenir de Taïwan et
c'est ce que nous allons faire
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau débat doc en commençant par
vous François godmond bienvenue vous
êtes historien et sinologue conseillé
pour l'Asie à l'Institut Montaigne et
votre dernière ouvrage s'intitule Les
Mots de seigin Pink publié aux éditions
Dalloz également avec nous Marc julienne
bienvenue bonsoir vous êtes chercheur en
relation internationale et responsable
des activités Chine au centre azi de
Liffré l'Institut français des relations
internationales bien
face à Shanghai check et les
nationalistes chinois et puis la suite
et la date clé dans le dossier qui nous
concerne aujourd'hui et bien elle a lieu
en
1971 et c'est aux Nations Unies on
regarde un premier extrait le 25 octobre
1971 au siège des Nations unies
à l'issue d'une séance plénière
historique et houleuse la Chine
communiste fait son entrée à l'ONU
adopte
[Musique]
de Chine pouvait-elle dès lors coexister
dans cette assemblée impossible pour les
deux rivaux historiques Mao et
shankshake la Chine est une indivisible
alors est-ce que tout commence là
François godemande ce fameux jour
d'octobre 1971 et il est dit dans ce
documentaire que Shanghai check portrait
une très lourde responsabilité sur ce
qui s'est passé ce jour-là aux Nations
Unies est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ça
qui était l'héritier de la République de
Chine qu'il a gouverné depuis les années
20 il a été le jumeau le général en chef
commandant la Chine jusqu'en 1949 il
était attaché à cette légitimité donc
c'est même au moment de la
reconnaissance de la Chine par De Gaulle
en 64 qui va même l'autre l'autre
tournant important sur le plan
diplomatique pour ces décennies là
premier grand chef d'État à reconnaître
la Chine populaire Charles de Gaulle à
la tête de la France qui n'avait jamais
de ceux qui reconnaissaient les les
régimes mais pas les États et qui donc
comme les Britanniques notamment cause
donc on les Portugais d'autres avaient
déjà des relations avec la gym populaire
mais ce qui ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
Chokri check s'était vu proposer en 64
d'avoir une forme de présence
diplomatique française à côté un système
et il avait refusé pour lui c'était tout
ou rien il perdait tout si il
abandonnait la souveraineté diplomatique
en 1971
est-ce que les États-Unis ont proposé
un deal un échange quelque chose à
changait check pour accepter ça a été ça
a été tout cas
les États-Unis de la Chine populaire
plus tard sur Jimmy Carter c'est le
fruit de circonstances internationales
et stratégique nouvelle et d'un tournant
stratégique américain qui prioritisait
une forme de coordination avec la Chine
pour contrer l'ours soviétique
Taïwan ne pesait pas grand chose dans
l'équation il faut ajouter qu'en 71 il y
avait moins de dangers militaires pour
Taïwan qu'il n'y en a aujourd'hui la
Chine était exemples à la sortie de la
Révolution culturelle qui était
d'ailleurs pas complètement terminée en
plus si vous voulez et donc les
États-Unis pouvaient jouer sur du
velours maintenir leur troupes quand
j'ai été étudiant en Taïwan en 1974
elles étaient encore là avec les bases
c'était encore la force dominante qui
maintenait donc on peut dire que
l'équilibre stratégique il était là il
était pas menacé alors résultat et c'est
ça nous est dit dans le film que nous
venons de voir Taïwan se retrouve
aujourd'hui au banc des nations deuxième
extrait et on en parle juste après
malgré tous ces efforts pour se
différencier de la grande Chine voisine
Taïwan ce pays de fête et pourtant au
banc des nations depuis 50 ans absent de
toutes les grandes organisations et
assemblées internationales
un pays figé pétrifié contraint par sa
propre histoire
même les grandes démocraties lui
tournent le dos
possédant pourtant tous les attributs
d'un État souverain Taïwan ne peut
compter aujourd'hui que sur une
quinzaine de petits États et territoires
en tête desquels le Vatican alors
conséquence de ce qu'on vient de se dire
avec François godemande
Taïwan c'est une sorte d'ovni sur le
plan international
ce qui rend les choses particulièrement
complexes là je voudrais que vous aidiez
à définir ce qui est Taïwan aujourd'hui
aux yeux de du droit international par
exemple mais le débat n'est pas tranché
en fait comme ça a été dit au début du
documentaire pour les juristes en fait
on peut considérer Taïwan les
caractéristiques de l'État dans Taïwan
dispo c'est à dire une population un
gouvernement une armée un drapeau etc ce
qui fait que c'est toutes les
caractéristiques d'un état donc on dit
que Taïwan est un état de fait de facto
par contre en droit des yurets c'est le
débat n'est pas tranché puisque certains
considèrent que le l'état la qualité
d'État provient du fait de la
reconnaissance internationale et là sur
ce point-là Taïwan est reconnu que par
13 États des micros États insulaires
dans le Pacifique dans les Caraïbes et
puis le Vatican en Europe et d'autres
considèrent que non non ce n'est pas la
reconnaissance par la communauté
internationale qui fait état ce sont les
caractéristiques intrinsèques et à ce
moment-là on peut considérer que Taïwan
est pleinement un état mais donc le
débat n'est pas tranché qui revendique
l'indépendance pour Taïwan aujourd'hui
pas les États-Unis on y reviendra tout à
l'heure c'est pas une demande des
États-Unis par exemple l'indépendance de
Taïwan mais qui la revendique
aujourd'hui c'est le même pays qui
reconnaissent officiellement Taïwan ah
non pas du tout de toute façon je pense
que la question de l'indépendance est
une question à poser au taiwanais pas au
reste de la communauté internationale
même pas au pays qui reconnaissent
Taïwan comme un état eux considèrent que
cet état est de facto indépendant mais
c'est justement le grand intérêt de la
politique même contemporaine taïwanais
c'est que avant le clivage était entre
unification réunification à plus ou
moins long terme et indépendance et
aujourd'hui c'est un débat qui s'est
étiolé qui s'est quasiment évanoui en
fait dans la société et aujourd'hui il y
a moins de 4% de la population qui
revendique une indépendance enfin qui
souhaiterait une indépendance à très
court terme puisque en fait le
gouvernement taïwanais actuel et la
population taïwanaise considère que en
fait ils ont comme je disais toutes les
caractéristiques d'un état ils n'ont pas
besoin d'aller plus loin sachant que
évidemment une déclaration
d'indépendance provoquerait un serait un
casus belli pour Pékin donc personne n'a
envie de cela ni les Taiwanais ni les
Américains quelques chiffres en 14 pays
reconnaissent officiellement 13 pays le
Vatican c'est pas fait
officiellement Taïwan en revanche Taïwan
a un véritable réseau diplomatique avec
quelques centipes diplomatiques et une
présence dans 75 pays selon la Fondation
pour la recherche stratégique
aujourd'hui tout à fait donc ce réseau
existe bel et bien tout à fait c'est le
point très important c'est qu'en fait il
est certes reconnu par 13 micros état
mais en réalité la présence
internationale de Taïwan est très
importante son réseau diplomatique ou
para diplomatique je sais pas comment on
pourrait le qualifier et très important
et d'ailleurs il a tendance même à
grossir on le voit même en Europe avec
des nouveaux bureaux de une
représentation évidemment on appelle ça
on appelle pas ça ni des ambassades ni
des consulats et donc il y a des des
un réseau diplomatique qui est très
important alors évidemment on se demande
si Taïwan à terme ne pourrait pas
connaître le même sort que Hong Kong
avec cette fameuse rétrocession donc des
Britanniques vers les la République
populaire de Chine qui a eu lieu à la
fin des années 90 et puis surtout la
situation congaisse aujourd'hui avec une
très sévère reprise en main de Pékin via
une une loi de sécurité
nationale qui a été appliquée et
fortement appliqué à du côté Hong
Kongais est-ce que c'est la voix quand
on suive selon vous Pékin aujourd'hui
vis-à-vis de Taïwan c'est vrai que quand
il y a eu les grandes manifestations de
2019 sur la loi de sécurité nationale
les grandes manifestations Hong Kong le
refrain qu'on entendait beaucoup à
Taïwan c'est aujourd'hui Hong Kong
demain Taïwan
aujourd'hui effectivement le même débat
est reposé et il va être certainement se
reposer à nouveau lors de la
présidentielle de janvier prochain mais
c'est vrai que la situation n'est quand
même malgré tout pas la même d'un point
de vue ne serait-ce que géographique
Hong Kong directement lié à au continent
chinois enfin à la République populaire
du Chine là avec Taiwan
détroit qui sépare effectivement et
Taïwan de la République populaire donc
la situation des mais effectivement pas
la même elle n'est pas la même non plus
sur un plan juridique administratif nous
on n'a pas à faire une région
administrative spéciale comme c'est le
cas de Hong Kong et de Macao
effectivement marque la rappeler
le Taïwan a son armée à sa monnaie à sa
propre diplomatie à sa politique
complètement indépendante effectivement
de quel moyen hormis le moyen militaire
on y reviendra bien entendu dans un
instant Pékin peut-il espérer
retrouver pleinement Taïwan dans son
giron alors un moyen juridique
un moyen juridique
non je pense pas il y a un moyen
peut-être économique sur le très long
terme et encore ça ça pose quand même
beaucoup de questions puisque on le voit
actuellement énormément en ce moment
Taïwan est en train de prendre ses
distances vis-à-vis de la Chine
populaire il y a une on parle beaucoup
du il y a un débat actuellement dans ce
qu'il faut découpler ou des risquer les
économies se débat qui se pose en Europe
se pose bien évidemment à Taïwan
également donc ça c'est réel François
Godman
votre question suppose qu'il y ait une
espèce de convergence progressive entre
Taïwan et la Chine et là existé à
l'époque des réformes en Chine elle a
existé pas tout à fait jusqu'à
l'avènement de Sitting mais à peu près
d'abord il y a un 2 millions de
taïwanais qui vivent en Chine qui
travaille et qui ramène d'ailleurs le
bénéfice de leur travail à Taïwan les
interactions humaines sont devenus
énormes et beaucoup de touristes chinois
qu'il est à Taïwan puis après tout si
vous regardez le compromis entre les
deux états en 1992 à Singapour les deux
étaient d'accord qu'il y avait une seule
Chine simplement il voulait pas dire
laquelle était la bonne il y a la
République de Chine et la République
populaire ce qui s'est passé à Hong Kong
a eu un rôle capital en même temps que
les événements que la tournant encore
plus autorité apk pourquoi parce que le
slogan un pays deux systèmes a perdu
absolument toutes cesifications pour
l'électorat Taïwan
c'est un slogan qui date de
n'est plus valable aujourd'hui à vos
yeux
il est pas souvent mis en avant
aujourd'hui par le par la Chine
populaire elle-même qui a conscience que
que c'est ça ne marche plus si vous
voulez donc les hypothèses de
réunification aujourd'hui bah il y en a
en gros deux par la force ou par la
coercition ce qui n'est pas tout à fait
la même chose la coercition c'est
persuader les lecteurs à taïwanais qui a
pas d'autres issus qu'un conflit serait
dramatique sanglant que ils auraient
beaucoup pas y perdre et par conséquent
de sur quoi leurs alliés ne sont
peut-être pas aussi sûr qu'il le croit
leur soutient à patouillé le précédent
du côté américain départ de du Vietnam
le départ d'Afghanistan et par
conséquent qui vaut mieux accepter
l'inévitable c'est une hypothèse mais on
en est très loin aujourd'hui la deuxième
hypothèse bien sûr c'est celle qui s'est
agitée de plus en plus aux États-Unis
c'est celle de l'emploi de la force
l'armée chinoise aujourd'hui
officiellement un budget qui doit faire
5 fois et demi celui de la France en
réalité peut-être 10 fois elle produit
trois fois plus de navires monitaire
tous les ans que les États-Unis leur
coûts est inférieure il est vrai à leurs
qualités ce serait une autre histoire et
donc quoi qu'on en dise l'hypothèse à
une certaine crédibilité Marc julienne
d'accord avec ces deux scénarios
possibles vous en rajoutez un autre de
scénario ou pas non non tout à fait le
scénario économique je crois
qu'effectivement il a il a fait long feu
puisque ça a été de 2000 de 2008 à 2016
lors de l'administration précédente du
KMT de combien de temps il y a eu cette
volonté en fait de de tisser des liens
économiques avec Taïwan pour essayer que
un effet de cliquer ce qui fait que les
liens se tissent et ne puissent plus se
détisser et le fameux mouvement des
tournesols dont on parle et ben voilà ce
documentaire était lié à un traité de
libre exactement par les autorités
précédentes que celles qui exerce le
pouvoir aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est ça
donc sur les 8 ans de double mandat du
coming-angle les choses il y a eu des
lignes aériennes du tourisme développé
entre les deux rives etc et puis a eu
cet accord de libre-échange ekfa qui
était en phase d'être signé et donc voté
et là la jeunesse taïwanaise d'une
certaine manière c'est soulevé a dit non
à investi le Parlement pour refuser
justement de d'aller trop loin dans
cette intégration économique qui était
une manière pour la Chine de d'intégrer
finalement à terme politiquement à
Taïwan et donc ils ont dit non et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui a
été dit sur Hong Kong les autorités
chinoises ont voulu appliquer le
principe de un pays de système qui était
le principe qui valait à Hong Kong sur
Taïwan et ça finalement ça a été un
repoussoir en fait pour les Taïwanais
quand ils ont vu ce qui s'est passé à
Hong Kong en 2019 puis en 2020 avec le
vote de la loi sur la sécurité nationale
c'était absolument impossible puisque
aujourd'hui tout le monde sait que si
officiellement un pays de système
continue d'être revendiqué par les
autorités dans les faits Hong Kong est
totalement absorbé donc un pays de
système ça voulait dire un seul pays la
République populaire de Chine et deux
systèmes parce qu'on compte un système
judiciaire économique légal même
culturels qui est un petit peu
différente celui de la République
populaire de Chine aujourd'hui les dés
sont jetés et il n'y a plus de un pays
de système à Hong Kong donc évidemment
que les Taïwanais n'acceptent pas et
n'accepteront pas il y a aussi une
tendance historique sur lequel contre
laquelle la Chine ne peut pas lutter
c'est que les Taïwanais de plus en plus
donc son ce sang de taïwanais puisque
les générations qui sont immigrées de
Chine dans les années cas fin des années
40 aujourd'hui sont de moins en moins
nombreuses et donc en fait les Taïwanais
de génération après génération se
détachent de la Chine de cette culture
ancestrale chinoise et donc je pense que
la Chine voit bien que à long terme la
tendance est que ça va être de plus en
plus difficile d'essayer de d'attirer de
manière coercitive ou en tout cas
attractive la population à taïwanaise et
donc c'est pour ça que l'option
militaire devient un risque en tout cas
devient une option plus crédible pour
les autorités faut vraiment vraiment
comprendre qu'en 2016 quand la
présidente saïwenn arrive au pouvoir
donc c'est un changement de majorité ils
arrivent au pouvoir le parti indépendant
enfin indépendantiste le DPP arrive au
pouvoir sur des idées de revendication
un peu indépendantistes et même ce
parti-là aujourd'hui ne parle plus du
tout de cette question de l'indépendance
la partie qui est devenue un parti
autonomiste en fait et donc c'est
intéressant de voir que paradoxalement
c'est la Chine aujourd'hui qui parle
beaucoup plus d'indépendance de Taïwan
pour agiter un peu le drapeau rouge en
quelque sorte le chiffon rouge et alors
que le parti au pouvoir ne parle
absolument plus de cette question là de
cette question de d'indépendance mais
plutôt d'autonomie et donc il y a une
vraie rupture qui a été faite avec
l'administration de saïwenn qui est
arrivé en 2016 et dont on voit
effectivement que les les deux sociétés
les deux pays les deux systèmes
politiques sont en train de s'écarter ce
que disait très bien Marc
progressivement et on voit pas
effectivement comment elles peuvent un
jour se réconcilier en quelque sorte
autour d'un projet commun en tout cas au
vu des chiffres ce parti démocrate
progressiste qui est donc au pouvoir sur
place à Taïwan depuis 2016 avec la
réélection de sa présidente qu'on a vu
dans le documentaire que nous venons de
voir a été marqué par une volonté
justement de découplement économique que
vous évoquez tout à l'heure ça se voit
dans les chiffres en 2022 c'était la
Chine était la première destination des
investissements de Taïwan mais ça ne
représentait déjà plus qu'un tiers des
investissements de Taïwan alors que
disons plutôt c'était deux tiers donc
cette politique de découplement
économique elle est bien été mise en
oeuvre et se poursuit aujourd'hui à
Taïwan pour
vis-à-vis de la République populaire de
Chine c'est bien ce que vous nous dites
c'est pas vraiment un découpe un
découplage de des économies c'est une
réduction des risques de la part de
Taïwan ça c'est vrai que c'est mis en
place à partir de 2016 parce qu'il y a
une force il y avait une force très
forte dépendance mais ça reste
économique ça reste effectivement Taïwan
reste le premier enfin le premier
partenaire de Taïwan ça reste
effectivement la Chine donc là c'est une
réalité d'autre part il y a eu une
politique qui a été introduite par
l'administration de saïwenn en 2016 qui
est politique à destination du Sud pour
effectivement diversifier les chaînes
d'approvisionnement et investir beaucoup
plus vers l'Asie du sud-est vers l'Inde
notamment Berlin notamment pour réduire
la dépendance à la Chine quand on parle
aujourd'hui en Europe en Union
Européenne de dérisquer les relations
économiques et commerciales avec la
Chine c'est exactement ce que Taïwan a
fait et le mouvement avait commencé
auparavant pourquoi parce qu'il y avait
aussi une stratégie chinoise à la fois
de punitions et parfois de récompense
pour essayer d'orienter l'électorat
taiwanais par exemple de façon tout à
fait incroyable c'est dans le sud de
Lille qui avait le plus de partisans de
l'indépendance de taïwanais de souche
assez hostile au mont continentaux en
général c'est eux qui ont les récoltes
de fruits tropicaux la Chine a ouvert
les bras aux fruits tropicaux produits
dans cette région en espérant capter les
dernières elles électorat ça n'a pas
marché Taïwan est aujourd'hui avec 24
millions d'habitants le 9e partenaire
commercial des États-Unis je sais pas si
vous vous rendez compte de ce que ça
représente et on n'a pas encore cité un
facteur qui colossal c'est que c'est de
loin le premier producteur mondial de
semi-conducteur le carburant de
l'économie du 21e siècle si vous voulez
ça c'est le navire amiral de l'économie
taïwanais
c'est extraordinaire ce succès dans ce
domaine-là mais c'est pas complètement
nouveau parce que Taïwan c'était
spécialisé dans des créneaux avec gagner
ces créneaux les uns après les autres
aujourd'hui la Chine a une autre échelle
pour des crédoux industriels standards
mais Taïwan reste en avant dans ce
domaine crucial donc c'est pas du tout
je veux dire quand en Europe on se dit
c'est très loin ça a pas de rapport avec
nos vies si on a un très étroit une
crise dans les trois de Taïwan ou une
prise de contrôle de Taïwan par la Chine
aurait des conséquences économiques
immédiates pour nous alors le pouvoir en
place à Taïwan tente de diminuer sa
dépendance économique vis-à-vis de la
République populaire de Chine en
revanche elle semble de plus en plus
dépendantes de Washington sur le plan
militaire celle-là toujours été en
réalité parce que le les Etats-Unis sont
j'allais dire à tort une garantie de
sécurité non puisque la politique
américaine c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'ambiguïté stratégique donc c'est à
dire que les Américains depuis 1979
depuis le jour où ils ont cessé de
reconnaître la République de Chine comme
la Chine mais la République populaire de
Chine ils ont quand même le Congrès
américain à voté une loi le Taïwan all
elections actes qui encadre les
relations avec Taiwan et donc l'objectif
était de fournir à Taïwan ses capacité
d'autodéfense pour faire face à une
invasion Taïwan mais il jamais il n'a
été dit ou presque que les États-Unis
viendraient au secours de Taïwan en cas
de en cas de problème je dis presque
parce que en réalité ces dernières
années le président Biden a au moins
quatre reprises je crois
a fait des sons c'est pas vraiment si ce
sont des gaffes ou mais en tout cas dans
des conférences de presse de manière
assez spontanée a dit que oui il
défendrait Taïwan en cas de crise donc
cette amplitude la première fois c'est
le président de taiwanaise qu'on a vu en
images
dit oui nous avons des militaires
américains qui sont sur notre site
officiellement une première secrète
polichinelle ça savait un peu ce sont
des instructeurs donc c'est pas une base
militaire américaine on en est très très
loin donc en tout cas les États-Unis
face à la coercition chinoise qui
augmente depuis 2020 il y a des
opérations militaires quotidiennes
aériennes et navales dans le détroit où
autour de Lille et donc les américains
affirment un peu plus leur soutien
politique et militaire pour que reste
crédible cette ambiguïté stratégique
puisque si la Chine augmente la
coercition mais qu'en face les
Etats-Unis ne répondent pas et ne font
rien cette ambiguïté stratégique la
crédibilité américaine commence à
vaciller et d'ailleurs c'est
probablement ce que je cherche à tester
les Chinois les Chinois en faisant ces
opérations là en fait teste la
résistance à la fois de l'armée
taïwanaise mais aussi teste la réaction
de l'armée américaine et des autres pays
dans la région et ce soutien américain
et même parfois une pression parce que
sur les deux dernières années on a vu
l'administration bagdone et même la
précédente
les Taïwanais à changer leur stratégie
de défense à adopter une stratégie
asymétrique c'est à dire acheter des
petites armes développées de une
technique de guérilla en fait pour ne
pas devoir affronter de face l'Armada
chinoise qui est en face d'elle et donc
de il y a vraiment de la part de
Washington une volonté de dire
défendez-vous autrement on veut bien
vous aider mais des fois vous aussi
autrement donc il y a vraiment un
partenariat sur le plan militaire et
défensif qui s'y est effectivement
renforcé ces dernières années c'est
comme tout le paradoxe c'est-à-dire les
États-Unis ne revendiquent pas
l'indépendance pour Taïwan mais continue
à armer
Taïwan défendre le statut quo face à la
République l'ambiguïta stratégique à
laquelle par parenthèse de souscrivons
nous aussi je crois que c'est hier
aujourd'hui que le Président de la
République française a fait une
déclaration pour rappeler que la
politique de la France et de l'Europe
tenaient à deux mots le maintien du
statu quo et ne pas prendre d'initiative
de force c'est entre ces deux pôles que
se situe que se situe le débat
personne ne veut effectivement affronter
la Chine on peut d'ailleurs hésiter
honnêtement sur ce qu'est l'identité
taïwanaise est-ce que vraiment ça n'est
pas du tout chinois beaucoup de
taïwanais aujourd'hui le pensent mais
c'est un peu le fruit d'une évolution
politique peut-être pas au départ de la
culture de la langue on parle la même
langue qui parlait à Taïwan de l'autre
côté du détroit dans la province voisine
mais c'est un fait politique et si les
États-Unis renonçaient à être présent et
à à s'accrocher si vous voulez devant
les les les pointes que lancent la Chine
ils perdrait toute crédibilité en Asie
orientale il la perdrait vis-à-vis du
Japon il la perdrait vis-à-vis de la
Corée il a perdrait vis-à-vis de
certains pays de laséanes donc ils n'ont
en réalité pas le choix ça ne leur plaît
pas ils ne souhaitent pas par exemple un
candidat politique à Taïwan qui
relancerait la thèse de l'indépendance
alors ça on va en reparler simplement ce
qui s'est passé en Ukraine cette guerre
déclenchée en
Ukraine euh est-ce que ça influe un tant
soit peu sur
la manière dont si j'ai une ping euh
envisage la suite pour pour Taïwan et
envisagerait éventuellement un conflit
en main à Taïwan est-ce que ça a changé
l'approche
des dirigeants chinois c'est difficile à
dire certainement dans les premières
semaines dans les premières mois il y a
dû avoir des réflexions et des révisions
des plans stratégiques de la Chine mais
d'un autre côté il y a aussi une
condescendance assez forte de du de la
Chine du de l'équipe dirigeante chinoise
envers la Russie et puis de dire que
donc finalement peut-être que si la
Russie n'a pas réussi son son offensive
c'est aussi parce que c'est une vieille
armée etc et que la Chine se sent
beaucoup plus moderne beaucoup plus
jeune ce sont vraiment la puissance du
21e siècle donc je sais pas s'ils vont
tirer toutes les leçons en revanche la
question est aussi sinon encore plus
intéressante dans le sens inverse quels
sont les leçons que Taïwan tire de la
guerre en Ukraine et là elles sont je
pense très importantes et là on a vu une
évolution concurrente en peine un an de
la position de la stratégie de défense
de Taïwan Arnaud parlait de stratégie de
défense asymétrique que pour laquelle
l'armée taïwanaise était assez
imperméable il y avait des débats
difficiles vraiment de de mettre en
œuvre cette idée-là et en fait on voyant
la société ukrainienne ce soulevait en
utilisant des moyens symétriques
finalement ils se sont rendus compte de
l'important justement de la de la
capacité de résistance ou de résilience
de la société et donc il y a eu des
évolutions très fortes il y a eu le vote
d'une loi pour réformer le service
militaire qui passe de 4 mois à 12 mois
c'est quand même colossal avec un très
fort soutien de la population et puis
aussi une réforme de la de la réserve
pour améliorer la préparation et
l'entraînement il nous reste cinq
minutes on va parler d'une échéance
essentielle évidemment à Taïwan élection
présidentielle élection législatives
c'est normalement pour janvier 2024 donc
c'est vraiment tout proche quels sont
les enjeux les rapports de force qui
existent en ce moment dans cette
pré-cagne ou peut-être déjà cette
campagne pour ces élections sur place à
Taïwan campagne oui effectivement qui a
démarré tout doucement on a déjà les
trois candidats qui sont déclarés le
candidat du parti au pouvoir aujourd'hui
le PDP le candidat du Community est
également été désigné et un troisième
candidat indépendant qui vont
s'affronter donc c'est une c'est une
élection importante puisque c'est la fin
du double mandat de timewen qui était lu
en 2016 et qui va s'en aller donc et qui
ne peut pas se représenter une troisième
voilà tout à fait donc c'est une c'est
un vrai tourment pour Lille sur le fond
évidemment de tension on vient de
l'évoquer beaucoup entre la Chine et
Taïwan si évidemment documentaire que la
vie politique finalement elle est entre
les les pros et les anti rapprochements
avec la Chine populaire voilà c'est ça
la ligne aujourd'hui c'est toujours le
cas j'imagine en grande en grande partie
François vous êtes pas totalement il y a
quand même des données intérieures
importantes pendant longtemps
l'électoratéronais n'était pas si
content de ça de Madame ça et elle est
un peu raide elle est pas très charis de
faire c'est comme ça qu'on la surnommé
peut-être en référence
d'une personnalité politique française
de premier plan qui était gouvernement
d'accord et ça vous voyez elle suscitait
pas la passion vous parlez d'Elisabeth
borne
mais elle a réussi pendant 10 ans parce
que face à une Chine qui était
absolument déchaînée elle a gardé son
calme elle a contrôlé les forces
indépendantistes qui existent évidemment
dans son courant elle a été vraiment
très très pragmatique aujourd'hui après
10 ans le meeting d'angle le le Parti
démocrate progressiste il a encore à peu
près 30 31 34% de soutien de socle
électoral après 10 ans de pouvoir c'est
pas si mal parce que c'est une
démocratie complète si vous voulez mais
que va faire la Chine
il y a encore une inconnue jusqu'en
janvier 27 dans cette affaire ça reste
le comington ça reste le comité même si
le actuel candidat du coming Tang est
moins visiblement
penchant vers la Chine que l'ancien
président qui lui vraiment c'est
complètement allié à Pékin jusqu'ici la
Chine c'est toujours trompée à chaque
fois qu'elle avait pourtant Dieu sait
qu'elle déploie des efforts à Taïwan
mais à chaque fois qu'elle veut faire de
la coercition ou de la menace et
l'aboutit sur le plan électoral le
résultat opposé c'est-à-dire elle fait
gagner le camp dont elle ne voulait pas
est-ce que ça va se produire une
nouvelle fois ou est-ce qu'ils sont
capables je ne sais pas d'une initiative
un peu plus douce si vous voulez d'ici
là
c'est encore une question qui est posée
et puis il y a la troisième force qui
existe aussi et force indépendantiste
évoquée à l'instant c'est ça plutôt
indépendantiste effectivement ce qui
tendrait indiquer que c'est difficile
pour elle de se rallier par exemple au
comité et c'est difficile de la parole
juste après difficile de faire des
pronostics puisque c'est une élection à
un tour avec trois candidats et on sait
par expérience que les élections
présidentielles à Taïwan se joue souvent
dans les dans les derniers moments dans
les dernières semaines avec beaucoup de
scandales et là l'intéress un scandale
qui agit beaucoup le parti au pouvoir
c'est Me Too qui a enfin j'allais dire
atteint les rives de Taïwan qui secouent
beaucoup le le parti donc ça ouvre une
période d'incertitude pour ces élections
c'est toujours compliqué de faire des
élections
au pouvoir c'est toujours compliqué de
faire des pronostics et là ça l'est
encore plus
il y a deux choses que je trouve
vraiment très très intéressantes dans le
dans les élections à venir la première
c'est qu'en fait les le clivage
politique se rétrécit très fortement ce
clivage c'était pro-unification ou prend
indépendance aujourd'hui
le parti au pouvoir ne revendique plus
l'indépendance et le parti d'opposition
le coming Tang ne parle plus non plus
d'unification puisque dans les deux cas
c'est très impopulaire donc ils doivent
recréer de nouveaux de nouveaux clivages
donc par exemple le coming Town dit que
voter pour lui c'est voté pour la paix
alors que le parti au pouvoir
actuellement c'est le parti de la guerre
les autres disent nous nous sommes le
parti de la démocratie et vous autres
vous soutenez la dictature la soumission
et la dictature et l'autre chose
intéressante c'est que vous l'avez dit
jusqu'à maintenant la jeune démocratie
taïwanaise
non c'est la démocratie la plus vivante
en Asie orientale avec une liberté de
presse et une floraison totale fait
partie des plus libres au monde avec une
certaine classe
c'était un trou avec jean-kai il faut
bien dire que c'était une dictature et
que sa solution s'était coupée la Chine
du c’était de couper Taïwan du reste du
monde aujourd'hui c'est le contraire
sont totalement ouvert on a parlé du
million de personnes ou des 2 millions
qui sont en Chine il faudrait parler des
millions de gens qui ont des cartes
vertes aux États-Unis qui travaillent
qui font des études qui reviennent y
compris dans le personnel politique un
peu moins vers l'Europe mais ils sont
quand même je vous l'assure très
présents en particulier en Europe
orientale par des investissements ce
sera le mot de la fin François Godman un
grand merci vraiment à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission
ensemble après ce documentaire pour
évoquer l'avenir de Taïwan et ces
fameuses échéances électorales prévues
en janvier 2024 vos réactions ça sera
sur hashtag des Badoc j'imagine qu'elles
seront nombreuses sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs je compte sur vous au passage
pour réagir à ce que sont ces réactions
de nos téléspectateurs merci à sel
massaliki comme à l'accoutumée m'a aidé
à préparer cette émission rendez-vous
pour un prochain débat doc et ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat à très bientôt
[Musique]